ladies and gentlemen we have the one and
only ludwig here
uh the man who king of streaming
the king of streaming i just watched
an episode the intro is great and i just
feel like you guys just looked up
wikipedia and you're like what does this
[ __ ] do
[Laughter]
what does this guy do he streams maybe
yeah yeah so twitch
you did a long stream right no no i'll
i'll tell you
what i really wanted to do when you got
here was we wanted to surprise you
with uh one of the biggest crypto
gamblers in the like [ __ ] in the
online universe train wreck tv no that's
a 14 year old named travis really no
i believe it
14 year olds go crazy i was just keeping
up on all the gambling drama and i was
laughing at how you were like uh
teenagers stealing their parents credit
cards to gamble like maybe
maybe it's more fringe than it is like
dominant because everyone's like dude
you're promoting it to kids and i just
thought it'd be funny to have two
teenagers walk through who are just like
[ __ ] whales and they're just sweating
it like bro i'm down a million luna is
killed me bro i'm out of here but you
gamble for real me yeah you don't crypto
gamble you gamble for real on your shoe
you do real life gambling i've i've done
it yeah i did like poker stream yeah
yeah
that's crazy game i'm like i'm addicted
i get like
oh yeah
i just did a uh
a 50 no you could i just
i just dumped all my crypto wallet into
a sports bet you're out of here uh no
you didn't get it what was that it was
like 50k that's all i have i don't have
like an insane i mean lot i have
in crypto okay that's all so i put
everything though on one sports bet
because i met this sports bettor in
vegas
and he called me
three times i didn't answer the first
two and then finally answered he's like
there's this girl she's in the french
open she just had a breakup she's like
crying she's really sad she's gonna lose
her game
and so i put he was like it's the better
the year i put all my money on it and
did you win well i the game was supposed
to happen yesterday it got delayed
and then i messaged him i'm like can we
pull out he's like no
so the game's tomorrow so she's had a
day longer to recover she said two days
she said 48 extra hours to recover from
her breakup
now maria i hope you're [ __ ] sad
right now
i hope you're crying in france just
missing him
you have good times remember he was the
best he was yeah i don't think you'll
ever find another guy
this is it for you you could have shared
a life together yeah it's crazy how he
left you for a girl that looks just like
you
did she plays a cooler sport like
pickleball
yeah she's really good at it yeah she
always wins your [ __ ] sorry that was
too far anyway
damn bro okay it's a lot of money i'm
really stressed out
so what do you win
if i win it triples up because she's
such a favorite to win she's like fourth
best in the world and you bet on her i
bet again
because she went through a breakup oh
right right so i don't even know her
opponent's day i don't even know what
i'm betting on
i only know that she said and crying
went through a breakup
and then this is it for my gambling
adventure what do you mean i'm quitting
after sure yeah that's what they all say
no
no for real guys yeah for sure we
believe no i'm done now we definitely
believe that this is it is it hits
uh-huh then you're quitting well i can
play with the earnings but
i walk home with my principal
right that's important train wrecks tv
do you know this guy of course yeah he's
the legend yeah i watched him last night
for three hours he went down two million
dollars on slaughter
my buddy's always sending me clips of
train i'm like how many times has this
guy won a bazillion dollars yeah on
twitch it's a lot it's so often he went
down two million dollars oh yeah in one
night in a few hours
like how much money does he have
he's gotta have like
20 million i imagine at least just in
like crypto money to gamble with jesus
christ hell yeah dude we should get you
an xqc to box it out you mean excuse me
yeah yeah he's like 6'2 150 soaking wet
190 pounds here
i'm trying to build this beef you know
yeah you guys been going at it a little
bit yeah
if i'm gonna box someone
who's it gonna be
i think you just did it you can't box
women dude all right she has to play her
tennis game
all right that's that's not right she
she's gonna ask me after listening to
this yeah it's true after she wins yeah
like after i took your money i want to
[ __ ] you up too your [ __ ] would you
guys box
i i would but i don't want to box like a
[ __ ] 22 year old and get smoked how
old are you uh 23 so yeah at the box of
23 year old 24 yeah i don't know i was
yeah it's one of those things like
the creator clash was like one of the
coolest
things like youtube i mean boxing things
for sure but just like live youtube
events i've ever seen yeah like he did
an incredible job with it i thought yeah
it still is like really embarrassing
when you lose you know
yeah
yeah no it is yeah like i don't know
just like even people that clearly
didn't train and just did it for fun
like graham stefan it's not fun watching
him get the [ __ ] beat out of him
yeah no when it when it's one-sided it
doesn't look good i mean shout out to
michael reeves man he did exactly
what every i've man every time i watch
one of the youtuber boxing events i'm
like dude if
one of these people just trained a
little bit of head movement use some
body shots and like mixed it up they
would do well and he did that
yeah so well yeah but then he [ __ ] up
graham and then right after on like my
my home page on youtube it's like the
it's like the sigma song it's like boom
boom boom and it's like graham stevens
talk and he's like yeah i think i could
just probably beat michael up and then
it's just like a cut and it's like
michael
[Music]
i would not want that to happen i don't
want that matt watson was in my chat
yesterday on stream he just types in he
donates a hundred dollars and he's like
hey how's it going and everyone's like
[ __ ] lumo
face
and i'm like guys you know he's braver
to get in the ring and they're like a
[ __ ] idiot to get in the room no see
that's what i mean because he is brave
it's for charity it's a good thing to do
is to get in there but still when you
lose people clown you yeah it does not
look good it doesn't look good no unless
unless you
know
what i was going to say
ian's got a lot of respect from people
because he he ate that [ __ ] he ate those
shots okay yeah if you make it to the
end
like if you if you like people still
talk [ __ ] though
yeah like i said i was like i was
reading the comments on this new video
and they're like still got your ass beat
dude it's for [ __ ] charity you don't
watch this [ __ ] yeah also everybody's
immediately an expert they're like yeah
your feet just weren't set right you
were too straightforward you're too
boxed in yeah they're never boxing their
life yeah yeah yeah yeah i was doing
that i was watching i was like ian yikes
i wouldn't be fighting mike like that
[Laughter]
i would be doing it much better it was
good they did raise a lot they did yeah
it was like a million million bucks yeah
yeah probably how much they'll have to
spend to get like matt watson his
recovery yeah
alzheimer's that he will definitely get
a [ __ ] loser yeah 10 years the
all-stars is coming matt you're [ __ ]
damn bro and now i'm picturing matt
watson putting on like 50 60 pounds
getting in like crazy shape and you
fight someone that's like even and he
like murders that guy it's like
uncomfortable yeah and then he's looking
at the camera like oh that's the [ __ ]
up face now everyone's like okay okay
well that was one of the coolest things
about that event is well first of all it
was like the first time i've nev i i
haven't felt like [ __ ] watching like a
pay-per-view thing that was run by a
youtuber yeah i'm saying yeah like every
single one in the past has been like why
am i why did i just buy that yeah all
this money isn't is just going straight
into the [ __ ] pocket
i don't want to be watching this but i
have to yeah and this was the first one
i was like [ __ ] this is for a good cause
i can't wait for this to happen again
like this just happened every single
year right yeah it also taught you 20
ways to say the n word did you see the
chat what do you didn't see the chat no
vr chat is another
level oh yeah of racism yeah yeah that's
crazy it's pretty wild have you gone in
yeah to the virtual world yeah recently
for like fun
yeah
why i mean for the streamer in the world
he's like oh
[Laughter]
did you just walk through vr chat and
meet random people and go oh hi and
they'd be like
or did you get really into it and go to
like the the strip clubs at 2am where
they beat off
do you don't know about this no okay so
you were in the weinhard junior section
yeah yeah he didn't see the one yeah no
i'm not yeah you're you're not like me
and him rave like you guys jesus that's
really what's going on here we're just
trying to suss you out because we'll be
in there at 2 just yeah you guys
with this thing in your hand
oh i get it among us yeah
it's a game it's a game yeah during the
pandemic a lot of people played it yeah
there's a second version out now it
wasn't in the weenie is there a section
of that
i was like wait i missed this
you